dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly life ahead this
footage that you see here came freshly
from google deepmind's lab and is about
benchmarking reinforcement learning
algorithms here you see the classical
cart pole swing up tasks from this
package as the algorithm starts to play
the score is recorded that indicates how
well it is doing and the learner has to
choose the appropriate actions depending
on the state of the environment to
maximize this score reinforcement
learning is an established research
subfield within machine learning with
hundreds of papers appearing every year
however we see that most of them
cherry-pick a few problems and tests
against previous works on this very
particular selection of tasks this paper
describes a package that is not about
the algorithm itself but about helping
future research projects to be able to
test their results against previous
works on an equal footing this is a
great idea which has been addressed
earlier by open AI with a learning
environment by the name Jim so the first
question is why do we need a new one the
deep mind-control suite provides a few
differentiating features one Jim
contains both discrete and continuous
tasks where this one is concentrated on
continuous problems only this means that
state time and action are all continuous
which is usually the hallmark of more
challenging and lifelike problems for an
algorithm to do well it has to be able
to learn the concept of velocity
acceleration and other meaningful
physical concepts and understand their
evolution over time too there are
domains where the new control suite is a
superset of Jim meaning that it offers
equivalent tasks and then some more and
three the action and reward structures
are standardized this means that the
results and learning curves are much
more informative and easier to read this
is crucial because research scientists
read hundreds of papers every year and
this means that they don't necessarily
have to look at videos they immediately
have an intuition of how an algorithm
works and how it relates to previous
techniques just by looking at the
learning curve plots many tasks also
include a much more challenging
variant with more sparse rewards we
discussed these parse rewards in a bit
more detail in the previous episode if
you are interested make sure to click
the card on the lower right at the end
of this video the paper also contains an
exciting roadmap for future development
including quadruple locomotion
multi-threaded dynamics and more of
course the whole suite is available free
of charge for everyone the link is
available in the description
super-excited to see a deluge of
upcoming AI papers and see how they beat
the living hell out of each other
in 2018 thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]